In Islam, men and women are equal. But
in some aspects, the men have a degree
of advantage. Some aspects, women have a
degree of advantage. For example, if a
robber enters my house, if a thief
enters my house, I'll not say I believe
in women's right, I'll not tell my wife
to go and fight. I'll not tell my
daughter to go and fight because Allah
says in 4:34, Allah has given most
strength to one to the man. So I have a
degree of advantage in strength. So if a
thief comes, I will go and fight. I'll
not tell my wife or my daughter to go
and fight.
Let me give you another example. When it
comes to respecting the parents,
the child respects the mother much more
than the father in love and respect and
companionship. As per the prophet, the
mother gets the gold medal, silver medal
and the bronze medal. father gets a
consolation prize. So where it comes to
motherhood,
the women have a degree of advantage
over men.
But overall men and women are equal.
They are equal but they aren't
identical. This is called as true and
practical gender equality.
The western world
when they talk about equality, no men
and women equal everything.
Then why do you have boxing match men
and women separate have equal correct?
If men and women equal when you have
boxing match why do you have separate
for women and men when you have 100 m
dash 100 m race in Olympic why do we
have separate we have together so they
also know they are not identical this is
the problem
so they know it but they aren't there to
admit it
when you have an examination
in the school and college men and women
sit together because they equal correct
so Many aspect they exactly equal. Some
aspect men have a degree of advantage.
So in boxing match or in sports in 100 m
dash yeah men have a degree of
advantage. They can't compete together.
There are some cases in which women have
a degree of advantage.
For example,
when
like there are many objection which the
western world takes which time will not
permit me to do in the question in the
lecture in the question answer session
if you have any questions I can reply to
that. So if you analyze in Islam men and
women are equal. So this is true and
practical gender equality.
It is not the fake western talk of women
liberization which is a disguise form of
exploitation of a body, deprivation of
honor, degradation of a soul.
The western talk of women
liberalization.
It's nothing but a disguise form where
they degrade the status of the woman to
concubine to mistresses to society
butterflies which are mere tools in the
hands of pleasure seekers and sex
marketers in the name of art and
culture. You know when you have ads
when you have ads
for the car or the motorcycle who rides
the motorcycle more gender or gent or
woman who rides motorcycle gent but in
the motorcycle you'll always have a
woman most of the time.
See that
in the famous ad
I was told of BMW which is meant for the
youngsters. You have a lady standing in
the bikini in front of the car. Test
drive her now. Who the girl of the car?
What are they doing in the name of
women's liberalization? They are selling
our daughters, selling our mothers.
So this is just
trying to manipulate you.
That's the reason in Islam we really
have the true and practical gender
equality. We love them. We respect them.
That is the reason we institute the
hijab for the women.
There's hijab for the men also. Time
doesn't permit me to discuss that in
detail. So in short, men and women are
equal in Islam. But equality does not
mean identicality. I would like to end
my speech with the quotation of the
glorious Quran from surah is chapter
number 17 verse number 81 which says
when truth is in falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood it's by its
nature bound to perish.